bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de pourquoi sont-ils si
uniques je vous avais utilisé dans la
dernière vidéo que je souhaitais vous
proposer un épisode sur Wanda c'est une
héroïne que j'affectionne beaucoup et
vous allez le voir son histoire est très
singulière bien évidemment je le
rappelle comme ça à chaque fois mais le
concept de l'émission C'est quand même
avant tout de mettre les projecteurs sur
un personnage les comics retraçant
l'histoire de Wanda Maximov s'étale sur
plus de 50 ans donc nous ne pourrons pas
parler de tout sur ce si vous êtes prêts
ne tardons pas plus longtemps car la
vidéo est très conséquente voyons
ensemble pourquoi Wanda Maximov alias la
Scarlet witch et Sinik
[Musique]
notre histoire commence le 3 janvier
1964 après une première confrontation
nous présentons tous les personnages
désignés comme les mutants nous
retrouvons l'équipe des X-Men dans le
comics numéro 4 de leur série ces
derniers sous les conseils du Professeur
X sont en train de s'entraîner et
accessoirement passe du temps ensemble
sans courage et s'entraide c'est alors
que comme les deux faces d'une même
pièce nous retrouvons une autre team de
mutants qui tout comme l'équipe des
X-Men sont en train de manger ensemble
néanmoins un certain contraste est
présent puisque l'ambiance dégagée par
l'autre groupe n'est pas au beau fixe
les personnages sont en train de se
chamailler Mastermind comme il semble se
faire appeler provoque la jeune femme
désignée comme la Scarlet witch de son
vrai nom Wanda et cette dernière a
indignée par les propos de l'individu
fera appel à son frère incertain Pietro
dont le nom de code est Quicksilver
suite à cette bousculade leader du
groupe va enfin faire son apparition et
calmer le jeu il s'agit en réalité de
Magnéto depuis tout à l'heure nous
sommes en fait face à la Confrérie des
Mauvais Mutants une équipe de super
vilains accompagnant magnéto dans sa
conquête Wanda et Pietro agacé par le
comportement de leur partenaire voudront
finalement quitter le groupe sauf qu'il
nous sera révélé que le frère et la sœur
ont une dette envers leur chef magnéto a
en fait sauvé Wanda qui était menacé par
des humains car le pouvoir de la jeune
femme ainsi que sa condition de mutante
leur faisait peur étant un véritable
manipulateur magnéto va également se
servir de cet incident pour démontrer
que les mutants ont pour devoir de
régner sur le monde car les humains les
détestent et ont peur de n'étant pas
spécialement convaincu mais ayant une
dette envers lui Wanda et Pietro vont
finalement rester le plan mis en place
par magnéto accompagné de sa confrérie
va donc pouvoir enfin débuter le chef
des Mauvais Mutants a pour projet
d'envahir et exterminer Santo Marco un
petit pays d'Amérique du Sud dont le but
de montrer à l'humanité la supériorité
que symbolise les mutants grâce au
pouvoir de Mastermind la confrérie va
créer une illusion faisant croire aux
habitants que le pays est envahi par une
armée ce stratagème va permettre à
l'équipe de pénétrer l'enceinte du
palais principal et d'y poser une bombe
nucléaire bien évidemment au même moment
les X-Men qui ont appris la nouvelle
vont intervenir nous offrons au passage
la première bataille entre deux groupes
de mutants de l'histoire des comics à
terme la Confrérie des Mauvais Mutants
réussiront à s'échapper cependant avant
de s'enfuir Pietro va finalement
désarmer la bombe nucléaire sans en
informer magnéto les X-Men seront
surpris de cette intervention mais grâce
à ça le pays de Santo Marco sera
finalement sauvé qui dit premier comics
dit première analyse suivons les bonnes
vieilles traditions la première
apparition de Wanda est intéressante car
l'héroïne a simplement pour existence de
gros les rangs des mutants et plus
exactement les rangs de Magnéto qui à la
base est seul pour affronter les X-Men
Marvel semble vouloir créer une sorte
d'équilibre enfin c'est ce qu'ils
veulent nous faire croire Wanda et
Pietro ne sont pas si secondaires que ça
dans leur premier comics et l'image du
dîner traduit cette idée les personnages
sont au centre de l'image ils ont déjà
une identité visuelle forte on ressent
clairement qu'on n'est pas face à de
simples vilains méchants mutants comme
pour elle le symboliser Mastermind ou
Todd dont les couleurs sont d'ailleurs
ternes et le comportement très douteux
Wanda et Pietro font tâche dans la
Confrérie des Mauvais Mutants et on le
ressent dès le début et pour accentuer
tout ça penchons-nous sur le fond du
comics one day Pietro n'ont pas envie
d'être là s'ils sont présents c'est
seulement parce que Wanda a une dette
envers Magnéto et que Pietro du coup ne
veut pas abandonner sa sœur et pendant
l'invasion de Santo Marco le frère et la
sœur sont à plusieurs reprises pris de
doutes pourquoi doit-on faire peur à ses
pauvres gens pourquoi on doit leur faire
du mal ça n'a aucun sens et au final
l'action ultime du comics sera que
Pietro va désinstaller la bombe en
secret Quicksilver et lascar detwitch ne
sont pas de mauvaises personnes et au
contraire c'est annonciateur de leur
futur ils sont des héros notre bande de
joyeux lurons sous la direction du tyran
magnéto continueront leurs aventures dès
les comics X-Men suivant avec également
une confrontation avec Thor dans le
journées into mystery numéro 109 ainsi
qu'un cours focus sur Rwanda et Pietro
dans Strange numéro 128 où ces derniers
alors qu'il souhaite déserter magnéto
vont finalement se faire traquer par la
torche et la chose des Quatre
Fantastiques car Quicksilver et la
Scarlet witch font partie de la
Confrérie des Mauvais Mutants cette
histoire aura finalement pour effet de
faire rebrousser chemin à Wanda et
Pietro qui retourneront sous la
protection de Magnéto néanmoins cela
nous permet de souligner quand même que
plus nous avançons plus ou unday Pietro
veulent fuir la Confrérie des Mauvais
Mutants les deux Européens approchent du
point de rupture et la scission va
finalement s'opérer nous sommes dans le
X11 des X-Men et nous sommes témoins de
l'intégration d'un nouveau personnage
soupçonné d'être un mutant détectés par
les X-Men ainsi que par la Confrérie
tout le monde partira à sa recherche
c'est alors que le drôle de personnage
qui s'auto proclame comme l'étranger va
finalement faire face à Magnéto et sa
banque un but de lui-même comme tous les
grands méchants magnéto souhaite que le
vieil homme rejoigne sa team et pour ce
faire il va le provoquer en lui faisant
une démonstration de ses pouvoirs bien
évidemment il n'aurait pas dû l'étranger
va directement répliquer et Mastermind
va prendre pour l'entièreté du groupe
leur affût provoqué par l’altercation va
d'ailleurs attirer les X-Men présent
dans la ville qui cherchait le fameux
nouveau mutant c'est alors qu'un combat
va éclater entre les deux groupes mais
vu que magnéto a son attention focalisée
sur l'intrigant vieil homme c'est Wanda
et Pietro qui devront gérer les X-Men
Quicksilver se fera neutraliser par
Iceman et Wanda désormais contre tous
arrêtera le combat signifiant quel tout
ce qu'il importe à présent c'est que son
frère soit décongelé Cyclope va donc
utiliser le rayon de ses yeux pour
désintégrer la glace retenant Pietro et
à partir de ce moment sans trop pour le
frère et la sœur les X-Men n'ont pas à
s'inquiéter leur allégeance à Magnéto et
désormais terminé il y en a marre
d'obéir à un tyran ça suffit de
participer à des combats qui ne sont pas
les leurs il est désormais temps pour
Rwanda et Pietro de retourner en Europe
et arrêter les combats inutiles entre
mutants enfin il ne sera révélé que
l'étranger était en fait un Cosmic Bing
l'un des êtres les plus puissants de
l'univers et que ce dernier était
présent sur terre pour étudier la
prolifération d'êtres humains avec des
pouvoirs extraordinaires suite à sa
confrontation avec magnéto qui a
continué de le provoquer l'être divin va
à terme le piéger et l'emmener avec lui
ainsi que le crapaud pour les étudier
sur sa planète à partir de ce moment-là
Wanda et Pietro vont migrer de Saga et
intégrer les Avengers mais avant de
parler de ça il faut que nous sortions
un peu de l'aspect histoire pour mieux
détailler tout ça en fait que ce soit
les X-Men ou les Quatre Fantastiques à
contrario des Avengers ce sont des héros
qui ont été créés pour former un team
les Quatre Fantastiques ont été écrits
pour être les Quatre Fantastiques et les
X-Men séparés ils ont été conçus pour
concevoir l'équipe des X-Men les
Avengers leur essence c'est tout
l'inverse se sont à la base des héros
qui ont plus ou moins tous leurs propres
saga leurs propres aventures leurs
propres histoires et du coup grâce à ce
concept et au succès de ce dernier
Marvel va souhaiter s'en servir pour
promouvoir ses autres personnages ils
ont envie notamment que Wanda et Pietro
deviennent populaires et du coup cela va
donner naissance à un concept qui
restera phare dans les Avengers des
comics c'est que nous allons avoir des
roulements nombreux seront les héros ou
personnages qui intégreront l'équipe des
Avengers mais pour éviter qu'il y ait
trop de héros d'un coup dans la même
équipe les anciens membres retourneront
dans leur saga ou du moins seront
éclipsés à un certain moment du récit
pour laisser la place dans le comics 16
des Avengers Nova le re-héros viennent
tout juste de sortir d'une immense
bataille les opposants au maître du mal
une équipe de vilains dirigée par le
célèbre Baron Zemo une fois le calme
revenu nous allons frôler une fracture
du quatrième mur puisque nous retrouvons
giant man alias empim la guêpe de son
vrai nom Janet et Iron Man soient Tony
Stark autour d'une table en train
d'amener l'idée qu'il est temps pour eux
de faire un break ils sont présents
depuis la naissance de la team des
Avengers ils ont mené de nombreux
combats tous plus dangereux les uns que
les autres et leur récente confrontation
avec les Maîtres du Mal les ont fatigués
est-ce que ce ne serait pas le moment de
prendre des vacances bien sûr mais le
monde a besoin des Avengers donc si nos
héros souhaitent partir ils doivent
avant trouver la relève c'est alors
qu'au même moment un certain hawkaï va
faire son apparition pour intégrer cette
fameuse team ne pouvant se contenter que
d'un seul héros Avengers actuels vont
faire part dans le journal de leur
souhaits de former une nouvelle équipe
vous vous en doutez et mais nos deux
Européens vont bien évidemment apprendre
la nouvelle désireux de se racheter de
leurs épopées sous la direction de
Magnéto Rwanda et Pietro contacteront
les Avengers ils seront reçus par Tony
Stark et se présenteront devant les
médias Captain America qui était absent
à cause de la précédente bataille va
finalement refaire surface il sera très
surpris de voir que ses coéquipiers
veulent s'en aller mais dans son cas il
souhaite rester un Avengers la team est
donc dessinée les nouveaux Avengers
seront composés de la Scarlet witch
Quiksilver ainsi que d'okai et auront
pour chef le célèbre Captain America dès
le comics 17 notre nouvelle équipe entre
rat directement dans l'action et leurs
aventures durera pendant un long moment
Wanda va énormément évoluer et
s'épanouir dans sa nouvelle vie on
notera d'ailleurs plusieurs caméos comme
dans la saga journée into mystery ou
elle fera la rencontre de Thor mais
également la saga tails of suspense ou
même la série dédiée au Dieu du Tonnerre
bref Wanda accompagné son frère vont
prospérer un long moment et ce jusqu'au
comics 47 des Avengers ou un très vieil
ennemi va faire son retour Magnéto et
son disciple le crapaud se sont enfin
libérés de l'étranger et reviennent sur
la terre le tyran désireux de reprendre
du service va souhaiter reconstituer sa
confrérie de vilain mutants et pour ce
faire il va envoyer un message codé à
ses ex disciples européens pour les
piégés évidemment wanda est Pietro sont
désormais des Avengers ils n'ont
aucunement envie de retourner dans la
confrérie mais Magnéto et patient il a
quelque chose derrière la tête pour
faire savoir au monde entier son retour
le tyran avec ses deux prisonniers vont
se rendre à l'ONU pour exiger que les
mutants est enfin leur propre nation la
réputation de Magnéto est en scalée
l'ONU sera clairement dans la méfiance
et le tyran ne pourra pas s'empêcher de
regagner son agressivité face aux hommes
le rendez-vous médiatisé va permettre
d’ailleurs aux Avengers de retrouver
Wanda et Pietro et une fois là-bas un
affrontement va éclater sauf qu'à cause
des tensions les policiers de l'ONU vont
intervenir et magnéto capable de
manipuler le métal va orienter la balle
d'un des gardes pour que Wanda se la
prenne de plein fouet témoin de la scène
Pietro le frère de Wanda va rentrer dans
une rage folle sa sœur a été grièvement
blessé par un humain de son point de vue
les mutants sont encore une fois
persécutés par l'humanité s'ils avaient
fait confiance à magnéto rien de tout ça
ne se serait passé Quicksilver après
avoir neutralisé les Avengers avec
magnéto quitteront la salle pour mettre
Wanda à l'abri finalement la jeune femme
aura survécu mais sa blessure lui a
causé un sacré choc et sans que les
autres le sachent Wanda vient de perdre
ses pouvoirs bon je pense que vous
l'aurez compris mais cette stratégie de
faire renouer one daytro avec leur passé
c'est pour un petit peu les éclipser et
permettre à enquêter Janet de revenir
parmi les Avengers nos deux Européens ne
resteront pas très longtemps dans la
Confrérie des Mauvais Mutants qui fait
désormais partie de leur passé magnéto
va connaître une nouvelle cuisante
défaite dans le comics Avengers 53 où il
va essayer de faire confronter à la fois
les X-Men et les Avengers et du coup
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre à
one daytro de fuguer le frère et la sœur
ne feront leur retour que deux ans plus
tard via les comics 75 et 76 des
Avengers il nous sera expliqué que ces
derniers suite aux événements avec
magnéto ont tenté de trouver un moyen de
redonner à Wanda ses pouvoirs par le
biais d'un vieux grimoire sauf qu'ils
ont en même temps par inadvertance
libérée un être extra dimensionnel du
nom Darkon cet événement va permettre à
nos personnages de se retrouver et
ramener au Hendaye Pietro parmi les
Avengers et fun fact c'est d'ailleurs à
ce moment que Wanda va rencontrer pour
la première fois un certain personnage
qui porte le nom de vision dont
l'intégration s'est faite dans le comics
57 des Avengers et en parlant de vision
tiens vous le savez tous ce va jouer un
rôle majeur dans la vidéo Wanda
puisqu'il est destiné à devenir son
époux et c'est un élément plutôt
intéressant que je souhaite souligner
car les Avengers contents peu de
personnages féminins à l'époque Wanda
aura souvent pour rôle d'être le love
interest de plusieurs super-héros
Captain America a déjà convoité la jeune
femme au caille ne sont jamais cachés il
est même jaloux de la romance naissante
entre one day vision et même dès son
premier comics Mastermind provoquait la
Scarlet witch en lui affirmant qu'elle
pourrait devenir sa femme sans compter
d'ailleurs les antagonistes qui ont
voulu se marier avec elle cette romance
va permettre à Wanda de s'émanciper et
accessoirement calmer les ardeurs des
autres personnages néanmoins je suspecte
qu'à l'époque cette relation ne devait
pas être si bien accueillie puisque dans
le comics Avengers 113 nous allons être
témoin de la médiatisation du couple
Wanda et vision un synthézoïde avec une
mutante bon déjà les mutants on le
connaissez pas extrêmement bien vu chez
les humains mais là une mutante avec une
sorte de robot c'est une indignation les
Avengers vont rouler sous les courriers
de gens pas contents et la Scarlet
twitch ainsi que vision seront même
victimes d'agression par des extrémistes
alors rien ne me permet d'affirmer quoi
que ce soit mais vu que Marvel a
toujours été très à l'écoute quand même
de ses fans et suivez quand même pas mal
l'actualité il arrivait quand même par
moment que ces derniers dénoncent
certaines choses dans leur production ou
du moins faisaient référence aux
réactions des fans ils ont brisé le
quatrième mur à plusieurs reprises dans
les comics il y a d'ailleurs aussi un
petit côté méta par moment où les
personnages savent qu'ils sont dans une
fiction enfin bref ce qui va nous
intéresser désormais c'est le premier
giant size Avengers une série de comics
qui va reprendre plusieurs comics et les
étoffer histoire de nous proposer une
aventure bien détaillée et si je vous en
parle c'est parce qu'en fin nous allons
avoir possiblement des explications
concernant les origines du frère et de
la soeur Wanda et Pietro un vieux
coéquipier de Captain America durant
l'âge d'or de Marvel va refaire surface
il s'agit de Weezer alias Robert Franck
l'ancien héros nous raconte que depuis
l'Âge d'Or et c'est finalement marié à
Miss America une excellente elle aussi
et tous deux après avoir retrouvé leur
identité civile on souhaitait avoir un
enfant malheureusement le couple sera
victime d'un essai nucléaire et seront
tous deux exposés à de fortes radiations
et tant en fin de grossesse durant
l'événement l'enfant des ex super-héros
deviendra radioactif et le gouvernement
pour contrôler la situation fera croire
au couple qu'ils vont s'occuper de
l'enfant et le soigner mais c'est tout
l'inverse qui va se passer le bambin
sera placé dans une capsule sous un
bâtiment gouvernemental et cependant
plusieurs années c'est alors qu'un
incident va se déclarer et l'enfant
désormais devenu un monstre va se
libérer et se déchaîner nos Avengers
accompagnés de wither vont tenter de
l'arrêter sauf que Robert sera blessé
durant la bataille et qui l'amènera à
l'hôpital là-bas allongé dans son lit et
mal en point le personnage va finalement
nous faire une autre révélation sa femme
Miss américain à l'époque serait
apparemment une fois de plus tomber
enceinte Wanda sera alors intrigué de ce
secret surtout que wither a énormément
voyagé en Europe durant son histoire du
coup par curiosité elle va lui demander
s'il connaît impossible en droit du nom
de windagor et là surprise Weezer nous
affirme qu'il est bel et bien allé à
wondhagore avec sa femme pour
l'accouchement là-bas il nous explique
qu'ils ont été accueillis par le maître
de l'évolution et qu'ils sont devenus
les parents de jumeaux malheureusement
Miss America va passer l'arme à gauche
quelques jours après la naissance de ses
enfants et nous pouvons s'occuper de ces
derniers wither a préféré les laisser au
maître de l'évolution sauf que quand il
est revenu des années plus tard ces
derniers avaient disparu Wanda va alors
faire le lien entre tout ça et
directement interprété quel est son
frère sont en réalité les jumeaux perdus
et Miss America deux anciennes légendes
de l'âge d'or je souhaitais vous parler
de ce comics car il traduit un mystère
qui va rester irrésolu pendant de très
longues années c'est l'origine de one
day Pietro 10 ans après leur première
apparition dans le comics X-Men numéro 4
Marvel se décide enfin à nous proposer
une origine Story pour ces personnages
mais bon c'est une origine Story qui est
quand même un peu bancale pour tout vous
dire même Pietro restera dubitatif
devant cette révélation en fait à ce
moment là on sent que Marvel ne trouve
pas de véritables direction pour le
frère et la soeur mais du moins ils ont
quand même envie d'exploiter ce mystère
pour tenir en haleine les fans et
d'ailleurs ce comics met quand même un
gros coup de pied dans la fourmilière
car depuis le début bah Wanda et Pietro
sont considérés comme des mutants là
avec des parents comme wither et Miss
America et bien cela pose question sur
leur véritable nature à l'époque on peu
de choses sur les mi-temps le gène x
n'existait pas il y avait jamais mention
d'héritage génétique comme il est fait
souvent chez les X-Men par conséquent le
fait que Wanda est Pietro est des
parents humains et bien cela gratte la
tête des lecteurs surtout qu'en plus
Weezer et Miss America ont été exposés à
une explosion nucléaire mais aussi car
les enfants ont été confiés à Herbert le
maître de l'évolution un véritable
savant fou de la génétique dont les
expériences ne sont même plus approuvées
donc ça se trouve même lui aussi est
intervenu dans le développement des
enfants suite à tous ceux ne nos deux
Européens reprendront le cours de leur
vie Pietro va finalement trouver l'amour
et même se marier avec cristal une
inhumaine dans le comics fantastique
fort 150 Wanda fera la rencontre
également d'Agatha Harnes une très
vieille sorcière provenant de Salem et
qui désire prendre la Scarlett witch
sous son aile pour lui apprendre à
maîtriser ses pouvoirs magiques car oui
nous en avons peu parlé mais Wanda est
désigné comme une sorcière malgré sa
condition de mutante
avec sa vie de vagabonde et bien elle
n'a jamais eu l'occasion de vraiment
pratiquer et comprendre son pouvoir
notre petite sorcière va également à
terme se marier avec vision dans le
comics giant size Avengers ce volume 4
ou Wanda prisonnière de Dormammu et sa
sœur Oumar se verra être sauvé par son
amant et après un combat en deux contre
deux et vision laissera éclater ses
sentiments demandant sa bien-aimée en
mariage chose qu'elle acceptera
évidemment mais faisons un bon dans le
temps car la prochaine histoire qui va
nous intéresser c'est le comics 182 des
Avengers nous sommes environ 4 ans après
le Giant size numéro 4 des Avengers et
il est temps de s'étaler sur une
histoire qui va durer pendant plus de 5
comics nos deux mutants sont
actuellement dans le coma et personne
n'arrive à comprendre pourquoi ils ne
sont pas morts mais ils ne sont pas
vivants non plus c'est comme si leur âme
avait quitté leur corps grâce à la magie
du scénario les Avengers trouveront
finalement une piste qui les conduiront
dans une une petite chambre d'hôtel
située dans un vieux quartier là-bas
nous retrouvons un vieil homme face à
deux petites marionnettes à l'effigie de
Wanda et Pietro nos deux Avengers sont
piégés à l'intérieur bien entendu
Quicksilver et la Scarlet twitch
demanderont leur libération mais le
vieil homme ne veut rien entendre
maintenant qu'il a retrouvé ses enfants
il ne veut plus les perdre Wanda va
alors rétorquer que ses parents sont les
super héros wither et Miss America
cependant leur ravisseur n'en dément pas
wanda est Pietro s'appelle en réalité
Anna et Matteo et ce sont tous deux ses
enfants pour appuyer ses propos le vieil
homme va même d'ailleurs nous révéler
son nom Django Maximov et dévoilé une
origine Story pour les jumeaux Wanda et
Pietro serait issus d'une petite famille
tzigane du centre de l'Europe comme
décrit par Django son fils Matteo est
doté d'une très grande rapidité et Anna
sa fille et quant à elle douée de magie
malheureusement les tzigan étant pour la
plupart du temps persécuté par les
autres DJ nous explique qu'il était à
l'époque obligé de voler pour nourrir sa
famille et un soir des individus en
colère vont intervenir pour se venger le
kanzigane a donc sombré dans les flammes
et malheureusement la mère de Anna et
Matteo au passage les deux enfants ont
finalement réussi à prendre la fuite
mais Django rattrapé par la foule en
colère sera séparé de ces derniers et ne
les reverra jamais tout seul après avoir
bien pleuré la perte de sa famille et
c'est finalement recentré sur ce qu'il
savait faire de mieux la fabrication de
pantins de bois et autres marionnettes
c'est alors qu'un jour en lisant le
journal il va faire le rose découverte
du recrutement de la Scarlet twitch et
Quicksilver parmi les Avengers qu'il va
directement reconnaître grâce à son
savoir-faire maximum pour retrouver ses
enfants va alors fabriquer des pantins à
leur effigie et par ce biais Anna Matéo
et Django seront enfin réunis après nous
avoir compté son histoire l'équipe des
Avengers ayant retrouvé la trace de leur
compagnons disparu vont enfin Django
dans un élan de panique tentera de
s'enfuir avec ses deux enfants dans les
bras mais vision réussira à
l'intercepter n’étant qu'un simple vieil
homme seul sans mauvaises intention
Django sera épargné et conduit au QG des
Avengers wanda est Pietro seront quand
même pas mal chamboulés par cette
histoire car même si ce qu'a raconté
Django maximum leur semble fou et bien
il y a quand même des éléments et des
détails qui les font douter et par
conséquent pour avoir le cœur net Wanda
va demander la permission aux Avengers
de quitter temporairement le groupe avec
Pietro afin d'accompagner le vieil homme
dans sa ville natale dans le centre de
l'Europe transia comme ça ils auront
peut-être enfin les réponses concernant
leurs origines après un long voyage nos
trois personnages arrivent dans la
fameuse ville située au pied du célèbre
montagor Django est heureux comme tout
le vieux bonhomme a retrouvé ses enfants
et en plus il partage un voyage avec eux
dans sa ville d'origine une fois arrivée
à l'auberge nos protagonistes ne
tarderont pas à aller se coucher mais
Pietro cogite il n'arrive pas à trouver
le sommeil il espère que le voyage lui
apportera des réponses car pour le
moment le mystère de ses origines
s'épaissit plus qu'autre chose ce cas
raconté Django le perturbe véritablement
car de son souvenir plein d'éléments
correspondent à ce que le vieil homme
lui a raconté mais il y a d'autres
souvenirs qui quant à eux ne se relient
à rien et d'après ce que Wanda lui avait
raconté de ses propres souvenirs à elle
les jumeaux auraient également un lien
avec la fameuse montagne qui JIT
derrière l’auberge la nuit porte en
conseil qui est trop va finalement se
recoucher mais de l'autre côté dans la
chambre de Wanda un drôle d'esprit du
nom de mode red va apparaître et
réveiller la jeune femme le mystérieux
personnage apparemment relié à la
montagne va expliquer à la Scarlet witch
qu'il est en possession de secret relié
à l'origine de la jeune femme mais pour
lui révéler cette dernière doit
l'accompagner jusqu'en haut du mont
wondagor une fois grimpé ou un daim
Audrey feront grâce à un vieil édifice
abandonné et après l'avoir parcouru leur
trajet les conduiront face à un
mystérieux hôtel avec un très vieux
livre dessus curieuse ou unda ira
l'inspecté sauf que modrede va
finalement trahir ouanda et l'attaquer
dans le dos notre Scarlet twitch est
tombé dans un piège de bon matin pieds
trop de Django iront chercher Wanda dans
sa chambre et Quicksilver face à
l'absence de sa sœur va très vite
comprendre que quelque chose d'anormal
se passe ni une ni deux pris de panique
il va parcourir l'entièreté de transia
en un quart de seconde pour retrouver la
jeune sorcière mais après avoir tout
fouillé c'est une habitante de la ville
qui va le mettre sur la bonne piste car
apparemment l'adolescente aurait aperçu
hier soir une drôle de lumière provenant
de la montagne étant désormais le seul
lieu restant que Quicksilver n'est pas
fouillé notre valeur grand frère foncera
instantanément vers la montagne mais
trop impétueux et impatient ce dernier
va chuter au milieu de sa course et
dégringoler de la la montagne avant de
s’assommer à son réveil notre mutant
aura un véritable choc en découvrant le
visage animal de celle qui la recueilli
et sauvé de son vrai nom Bova elle est
le résultat d'une des premières
expériences du célèbre maître de
l'évolution qui s'amusait à transformer
des animaux en être anthropomorphe sa
mission était de s'occuper des
nouveaux-nés issus des nouveaux hommes
créés par son maître mais un jour Bova
aurait une drôle de visite une femme
enceinte jusqu'aux dents et au bord de
l'écroulement se tient debout devant sa
porte ayant un instinct maternel Bova va
directement recueillir la jeune femme et
l'aider à récupérer après avoir appris à
se connaître la jeune femme du nom de
Magda qui vient de donner naissance à
des jumeaux va expliquer à Bova qu'elle
fait partie du cancigan situé plus bas
sauf que son mari a acquis apparemment
certaines facultés qui l'ont rendu très
arrogant et très dangereux à tel point
qu'il s'imaginerait presque dominait le
monde et prise de peur et inquiète pour
ses futurs bébés mag pas à préférer son
fuir quelques temps plus tard après
avoir pris le temps de profiter de ces
deux bébés Magda partira de nouveau
laissant derrière elle un message à Bova
de peur que son mari la retrouve et par
conséquent retrouve ses enfants elle a
préféré s'abandonner dans la tempête de
neige Bova va donc s'occuper des jumeaux
et avec son maître Herbert chercheront
un foyer pour les bambins c'est alors
qu'un certain couple va faire son entrée
il s'agit de Robert Franck et de
Madeline Joyce alias The wither et Miss
America le plan est simple Madeline
enceinte est au bord de l'accouchement
le maître de l'évolution pour se
débarrasser des enfants va donc faire
croire au couple qu'ils viennent d'avoir
des triplés sauf que malheureusement
vous le savez ce n'est pas du tout ce
qu'il va se passer Madeline à cause de
l'essai nucléaire de l'époque va donner
naissance à un bébé en très mauvaise
santé qui malheureusement ne va pas
survivre et cette épreuve aura été si
difficile que Miss America elle-même
donnera le dernier souffle quelques
jours plus tard face à ce tableau
Herbert et Bova vont donc se tourner
vers Robert Frank et lui faire croire
que Madeline a donné naissance à des
jumeaux mais ne supportant pas la
nouvelle que sa femme vient de mourir
Robert va péter les plombs et s'enfuir
de Windows à terme Herbert va enfin de
compte prendre les choses en main
accompagner des deux bébés il va aller
au kantzigane présents au pied de la
montagne et écrira l'illusion d'une
manifestation divine face à un jeune
couple les maximums mais éléments
intéressants les véritables enfants des
maximes Anna et Matteo viennent tout
juste de perdre la vie par conséquent
avec la pseudo intervention divine du
maître de l'évolution ils vont
finalement croire à une résurrection
Pietro et bouche bée il a finalement les
réponses qu'il était venu chercher mais
d'un autre côté il ne comprend pas
pourquoi il ne se rappelle pas de son
enfance grâce à Bova toutes les
histoires s'emboîtent mais cela
n'explique pas le de souvenirs dont il
est victime après tout ça l'ancienne
nourrice des jumeaux mettra en garde
Quicksilver concernant la dangerosité de
wundagor et à ce moment il va se
rappeler qu'il était venu pour retrouver
Wanda sauf que Wanda est dans une
mauvaise situation modered qui est
manipulé par le livre qui se révèle être
le Dark all de votant en réalité se
servir de la jeune femme pour invoquer
son maître grâce à sa magie hexagonale
ou en date en train d'influencer les
probabilités pour s'enfuir en vain mode
RAID la stopranet et nous dévoilera que
Wanda a été choisi à la naissance par le
démon pour être son réceptacle Pietro
face à ce qu'est devenu sa sœur ira à
toute vitesse appelé les Avengers en
urgence malheureusement ces derniers une
fois arrivé se feront neutraliser et le
démon dans le but de terminer pleinement
son rituel va se révéler au grand jour
nous sommes face au démon faisant partie
autrefois des Grands Anciens tonnes il
est le créateur et l'écrivain du Dark
old il est un être sombre qui a
influencé l'histoire de la sorcellerie
depuis l'aube des temps enfermé dans le
mont windagor depuis des siècles le
personnage réussira grâce au darkoz qui
lui sert de lien avec la terre à
accorder sa bénédiction à un nouveau-né
lui insufflant une énergie mystique il
s'agit de Wanda et grâce à cela cela lui
permettra de revenir un jour en se
servant de la jeune femme comme
réceptacle au final à terme à cause de
son inattention tonne n'a pas remarqué
la présence du fauve qui s'est déguisé
en chevalier de wondhagore des temps
anciens pour voler le Dark old Acton ce
qui va annuler du coup le rituel et
libérer les Avengers à terme ce sera le
personnage le plus pur de cette épopée
qui réussira à trouver la solution pour
sauver Wanda tonne ayant pris possession
le corps de Wanda Django a réussi à
récupérer l'âme de sa fille pour
l'insuffler dans sa petite marionnette
et depuis ce minus Pantin et grâce à
l'aide des gens qui l'entourent Wanda
réussira à inverser les corps
piéjanctonne dans la marionnette pour
clôturer l'affrontement Wanda lancera un
énorme sortilège qui va briser tout le
haut de la montagne hectone sera vaincu
définitivement à cause de l'éboulement
l'épopée et la bataille se termineront
sur le corps inanimé de Django maximum
qui a donné tout ce qu'il pouvait pour
sauver sa fille Anna et Matteo comme il
les appelaient lui rendront un très bel
hommage en lui façonnant une sépulture
nous avons clairement changé de vitesse
avec ces derniers comics beaucoup
d'informations nous sont transmises et
sincèrement cela fait du bien d'avoir
enfin une véritable aventure dédiée pour
Wanda lascarlet twitch et son frère
Pietro en vrai il y en avait vraiment
besoin car nos jumeaux n'avaient
toujours pas de véritable origin story
instaurer et plus nous avons plus nous
arrivions à ce que j'appelle le syndrome
Namor c'est-à-dire en gros qu'on a des
éléments de l'or parsemé par-ci par là
un peu partout à travers les années
introduit également par des dessinateurs
différents et à terme du coup on se
retrouve avec une histoire un peu
incohérente et avec beaucoup de
bricolages là avec cette épopée Marvel
prend enfin position et la véritable
histoire des jumeaux nous est enfin
révélé mais cela va même plus loin et
sincèrement je trouve qu'ils ont été
très forts sur ce coup-là car le comics
Avengers aomis nous dire qui était le
fameux père de Wanda et Pietro on sait
seulement que c'est un homme qui acquis
beaucoup de pouvoir au point de devenir
dangereux et c'est ce qui fuir Magda
néanmoins au même moment que la sortie
de cette épopée le comics X-Men 125 va
faire son apparition concrètement
l'histoire racontée on s'en fiche un peu
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la référence
nous retrouvons le célèbre magnéto en
train de planifier ses prochaines
conquêtes dans son vaisseau et pour ce
faire il utilise un appareil relié à sa
mémoire pour se remémorer ses batailles
face au X-Men sauf que tout à coup
l'esprit de Magnéto divague et l'écran
dont le mécanisme retranscrit ce qu'il a
dans sa tête nous montre le visage d'une
femme à la chevelure rouge il s'agit de
Magda le protagoniste va alors nous
dévoiler quel était sa femme et
cocombien il regrette le fait qu'elle
les fuit il y a longtemps de cela
magnéto est désigné à partir de ce
moment-là comme le véritable père de
Wanda et Pietro mais ça il ne le sait
pas encore la révélation ne nous sera
faite que trois ans plus tard dans la
petite série de comics vision and the
sky twitch sortie
1982 où nos deux tourtereaux ayant pris
leur retraite d'Avengers ont emménagé
dans une petite maison dans le New
Jersey dans l'histoire qui nous
intéresse nous sommes du point de vue
d'un mystérieux personnage en train de
parcourir le monde Wonder pour s'abriter
de la tempête le protagoniste ira
demander l'hospitalité à Bova et une
fois dans la maison ils échangeront sur
leur vie près du feu c'est alors que par
inadvertance Bova va divulguer
l'histoire qu'elle a vécu avec Magda et
que la jeune femme a donné naissance à
ses enfants qui par la suite ont survécu
le mystérieux homme à l'écoute de cette
annonce deviendra hostile il veut faire
cracher le nom des enfants Bova se
rappellera de sa promesse envers Magda
qui ne souhaitait pas que le père
retrouve ses bébés mais l'homme
inflexible se mettra à torturer la
nourrice et cette dernière dévoilera les
noms de Wanda et Pietro l'homme
mystérieux qui se révèle être magnéto
finira directement pour retrouver ses
enfants qui sont actuellement en réunion
de famille car Pietro et sa femme
cristal des Inhumains viennent d'avoir
leur premier enfant Luna bien évidemment
tout le monde sera hostile à l'arrivée
du terrible mutant et un combat va
s'enclencher mais tous vont s'arrêter au
son des pleurs de Luna magnéto va
comprendre qu'il est désormais
grand-père et c'est à ce moment précis
où il va révéler sa condition à Wanda et
Pietro le vieux mutant calmera par la
suite le jeu et se montrera bienveillant
envers ses enfants Wanda prise par
l'émotion ne pourra pas s'empêcher de se
demander pourquoi ces derniers
apprennent cette nouvelle que maintenant
c'est plutôt intéressant ce qu'ils ont
fait avec Manito à partir de ce
moment-là car le personnage change
complètement de visage ce dernier nous
révèle son lourd passé à cause de la
guerre et à quel point les atrocités qui
l'a vécu l'ont façonné à devenir le
puissant et sombre mutant qu'il est
aujourd'hui cela nous permet de mieux
avaler la pilule d'avoir un personnage
un peu plus nuancé plus apte à devenir
le véritable père de Wanda et Pietro
mais bon magnéto reste quand même
magnéto bref à partir de ce moment là je
pense que nous allons commencer à faire
de véritables bon dans le temps vers la
fin des années 80 c'est vraiment le
moment où je trouve que Wanda va glow up
car en réalité depuis le début elle
reste quand même assez secondaire à la
base elle est juste une mutante comme ça
de la confrérie et après quand elle est
une Avengers bah c'est une membre de
l'équipe qui va juste enchaîner les
aventures et les combats contre le mal
et c'est un point que je trouve quand
même pas mal important car malgré toutes
ces histoires et bien il n'y a jamais eu
vraiment de temps pour développer Wanda
et ce qui la compose véritablement alors
que pourtant il y a toujours des petits
éléments qui par-ci par-là sont amenés
pour développer et amener un peu plus le
caractère de Wanda mais ce n'est jamais
vraiment creusé si nous faisions le
point maintenant par exemple il y aurait
quand même des choses à dire sur la
protagoniste wanda est un personnage qui
a eu un vécu assez sombre avec beaucoup
de souffrance elle a été abandonnée en
cavale durant toute son enfance un
adolescence sans parler de la mauvaise
influence de Magnéto elle a appris ses
origines que récemment et après toutes
ces années à défendre l'humanité aux
côtés des Avengers on commence
simplement tout doucement à comprendre
que Wanda veut juste trouver le bonheur
et la simplicité et par rapport à ça
Pietro en tant que grand frère servira
énormément de référence pour Wanda quand
ce dernier va se marier avec cristal
cela interrogera la Scarlet twitch sur
ses propres désirs quand son frère aura
son premier enfant mandat commencera
petit à petit à songer elle aussi à en
avoir et c'est ça qui est pertinent la
Scarlet twitch n'a jamais eu le temps ni
même le droit de penser à elle elle a
toujours suivi ce qu'on lui a imposé de
faire ou parce que sa condition de
Scarlet witch la Rance spéciale elle
sera à maintes reprises instrumentalisée
par des entités malveillantes comme le
démon tonne par exemple mais tout ça
cela doit s'arrêter il faut du
changement et pour s'opérer nous allons
être témoin de l'arrivée d'un heureux
évènement grâce à l'initiative de vision
qui les Avengers nous allons avoir
l'émergence dans les années 80 d'une
seconde équipe les Avengers de la côte
ouest et cela a un avantage c'est que
vision et Wanda auront le temps de
développer leur histoire d'amour et
d'avoir une maison en parallèle du coup
de leurs aventures nous aurons une
courte série de comics nous montrant la
vie quotidienne de ce fameux couple et
ce qui va nous intéresser
particulièrement c'est la toute dernière
histoire proposée Wanda et
miraculeusement tombé enceinte et encore
plus surprenant elle est sur le point
d'accoucher nos deux tourtereaux sont
aux anges ils vivent le parfait amour et
la naissance prochaine de leur enfant
est une véritable victoire car personne
n'aurait misé sur une mutante et un
synthésoïde pour fonder une famille le
rêve de Wanda touche au but fonder une
famille est une belle revanche sur la
vie qui n'a malheureusement jamais été
tendre avec elle arrivé à l'hôpital le
couple sera accueilli par leur ami
Docteur Strange qui sera la personne qui
va mettre au monde leur enfant leur
enfant j'ai dit surprise alors que
personne ne s'y attendait Wanda était en
réalité enceinte de jumeaux un beau
symbole qui lui rappelle bien évidemment
sa relation avec son frère Pietro les
enfants de one day vision viennent de
naître c'est la première apparition dans
les comics de Billy et Tommy cependant à
partir de là la réalité va rattraper
Wanda et nous rappeler que la Scarlet
twitch n'a pas le droit au bonheur en
fait cette période dans les comics c'est
le début de la mise en place du rôle de
la Scarlet twitch et du développement de
ses pouvoirs depuis le début wanda est
simplement catégorisé comme une sorcière
elle n'a rien de véritablement spécial
on sait juste que voilà il y a le démon
tonnes qui est passé par là mais c'est
tout du coup pour rendre Wanda plus
exclusif je dirais Marvel va commencer à
développer tout ça et pour ce faire ils
vont reprendre un petit peu le schéma de
sa jeunesse du coup
pas de libre arbitre instrumentalisation
et manipulation et par conséquent cela
va propulser ouanda en termes de pouvoir
et d'importance sinon il n'y a pas
d'intérêt la naissance de ses enfants
est d'ailleurs la preuve du
développement de ses pouvoirs puisque à
ce moment-là c'est du jamais vu dans
l'univers Marvel wanda est en mariée à
un saint-thésoïde et bien voilà cela
veut dire qu'elle ne peut pas avoir
d'enfants normalement donc cela conclut
bien qu'elle les a créé à partir de la
magie pour démontrer l'unicité de Wanda
Marvel va nous compter que cette
dernière est en fait un élément clé du
plan d'immortus le disciple des thèmes
Keepers des sortes d'entités qui gèrent
le cours du temps par ce biais on nous
révèle que Wanda serait ce qu'on appelle
un être Nexus c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
est capable d'influencer le futur et
bien évidemment c'est quelque chose qui
est à craindre pour des maîtres du temps
mais pire que ça car cela ne s'arrête
pas là les enfants d'un être Nexus sont
un véritable risque pour l'univers car
ils auraient la capacité d'ébranler
par conséquent Immortus au nom des
thèmes Keepers va intervenir dans le
plus grand des secrets pour manipuler la
vie de Wanda déjà le cas de ses enfants
l'énergie qui a permis de les créer
serait apparemment reliée à Méphisto un
démon extra-dimensionnel du coup
Immortus va comploter avec lui pour
récupérer ses derniers et par le biais
de pandémonium un disciple de Mephisto
Wanda va perdre ses enfants et personne
ne pourra rien y faire pour apaiser la
sorcière
agathaarknès la mentor de Wanda aura
l'obligation de lui jeter un sort
affectant sa mémoire mais ce n'est pas
tout Immortus va également comploter
pour saboter le couple de la
scarletwitch discrètement il va isoler
vision grâce à ses subordonnées et le
démantelé puis le réassembler afin que
ce dernier perde toutes ses émotions par
conséquent vision n'éprouvera plus aucun
amour pour Wanda ce qui va totalement la
chambouler à terme Immortus sera révélé
au grand jour et réussira à se libérer
de cette manipulation elle sera même
beaucoup plus forte en termes de pouvoir
mais sera de nouveau seul sa famille
n'est plus c'était important de parler
de cet événement car c'est à partir de
ce moment où on doit véritablement
évoluer vers ce à quoi elle ressemble
aujourd'hui dans les comics on aura
enfin développement de la magie du chaos
enfin un développement du rôle de la
scarletwitch en elle-même dont notamment
cette capacité de manipuler la réalité
en elle-même et d'être un être Nexus
mais voilà tout ça c'est bien mais au
bout d'un moment il faut bien que
quelque chose arrive après tout comme le
disait le philosophe Ralph Emerson il
n'existe aucun secret qui ne puisse être
découvert
nous sommes dans le comics Avengers
numéro 500 sorti le 28 juillet 2004 et
c'est le début de l'arc 10 à sombeld
Avengers nos héros sont en train de
mener leur petites vitres tranquilles
dans le QG des Avengers sauf que tout à
coup les alarmes vont retentir alors
grande surprise leur ancien coéquipier
Jack le Valet de Coeur et de retour
alors que pourtant ce dernier était mort
curieux de comprendre la situation
Scotland alias Ant-Man ira sa rencontre
pour comprendre comment cela est
possible mais il n'aurait pas dû le
Valet de Coeur dont le physique nous
démontre qu'il a été ramené depuis les
morts affirme à Scott qu'il est désolé
avant de créer une gigantesque explosion
c'est la panique générale dans le QG des
Avengers personne ne comprend ce qu'il
se passe et pire que ça à cause de
l'explosion Scotland vient de rendre
l'âme cependant nos héros n'auront même
pas le temps de s'apitoyer car les
catastrophes vont s'enchaîner tout à
coup vision va apparaître accompagnée de
bottes Ultron qui vont attaquer les
Avengers sheilk va par la suite perdre
le contrôle comme si quelqu'un la
guidait à distance et Jennifer de colère
va se retourner contre ses alliés avant
de déchirer vision en deux les malheurs
s'enchaînants voilà que l'empire cri
intervient pour détruire l'équipe de
super-héros pris de court et dans la
détresse la plus totale aux Cailles pour
sauver son équipe va se sacrifier en
explosant le vaisseau mère le calme
semblant revenu les Avengers seront
dévastés qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
pourquoi toutes ces catastrophes
s'enchaînent Docteur Strange
actuellement dans une autre dimension va
finalement apparaître et nous révéler
que quelqu'un est actuellement en train
d'abuser de la magie la totalité des
Avengers restants vont alors débattre et
se questionner sur qui serait
d'organiser une telle chose et
malheureusement le nom de Wanda va
ressortir personne ne veut y croire la
scarletwitch est une bonne personne
jamais elle n'aurait fait ça jamais elle
n'aurait tué ses coéquipiers et encore
pire que ça son mari mais c'est bel et
bien le cas Wanda a organisé ses
catastrophes et Docteur Strange blâme
les Avengers en tant que Sorcier Suprême
des armistiques les Avengers auraient dû
appeler Docteur Strange quand Wanda
n'allait pas bien ils auraient dû la
pousser à ce qu'elle devienne la
disciple du Sorcier Suprême car
désormais wanda est une sorcière qui
possède un pouvoir qui la dépasse
complètement ce n'est plus Wanda qui
manipule la réalité c'est la réalité qui
contrôle Luanda la jeune femme a subi
bon nombre d'épreuves tout au long de sa
vie et sa réaction est tout à fait
normale donner un immense pouvoir à
quelqu'un qui a perdu sa famille et son
bonheur et voilà ce qu'il se passe
néanmoins Agatha avait normalement jeté
d'oubli à Wanda concernant ses enfants
donc pourquoi a-t-elle perdu le contrôle
et bien il nous sera révélé par le biais
d'un flashback Wanda lors d'une
conversation somme plus banale avec
Janet van DIN alias la guêpe l'une de
ses plus grandes amies a appris qu'elle
avait eu il y a un certain temps deux
enfants intrigués et en détresse la
jeune femme ira voir sa mentor Agatha
Hartness et l'obligera à tout lui
dévoiler de retour dans le présent nous
serons témoins que Wanda dans la folie a
finalement tué Agatha et vit dans une
illusion où elle a ramené vision et ses
enfants les Avengers la confronteront et
c'est Docteur Strange qui réussira à
stopper Wanda la plaçant dans une sorte
de coma magnéto suite aux mises en garde
de Shark Xavier arrivera sur la scène
découvrant que le Professeur X avait
raison Wanda a perdu le contrôle et
magnéto veut récupérer le corps de sa
fille pour trouver une solution
cela fait maintenant des jours que
Charles Xavier accompagné de Magnéto
tente de sauver Wanda mais
malheureusement la situation empire plus
le temps avance plus Wanda devient hors
de contrôle et accessoirement devient
dangereux pour l'univers c'est une
véritable situation de crise surtout que
Wanda à cause de ce qu'elle a fait ta
vision au caille et Scotland culpabilise
poussant son état à décliner encore plus
des mesures doivent être prises les
X-Men et les Avengers doivent trancher
que faire de Wanda aucune solution
n'existe Docteur Strange ne peut rien
faire chaque Xavier n'arrive pas à la
soigner les avis divergent donc est-ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas tuer la Scarlet
witch c'est alors qu'au même moment nous
retrouvons un Pietro effondré dans la
chambre de Wanda face à son père magnéto
le mutant sait qu'il n'y a pas d'issue
avec ce qu'a fait Wanda avec sa perte de
contrôle la mort et la seule option et
il ne peut l'accepter magnéto dévastée
affirme qui ne peut rien faire lui non
plus et que c'est finalement peut-être
la seule option les Avengers après leur
meeting vont finalement décider de
retourner voir Rwanda pour essayer de
s'entretenir avec elle sauf que plus
personne n'est dans la chambre pris de
panique tout le monde va partir à sa
recherche mais tout à coup une lumière
aveuglante va s'éveiller et le monde
sera différent sans savoir pourquoi nous
nous retrouvons au beau milieu de la
matinée Steve Rogers est désormais un
vieil homme et n'a jamais connu sa
période de congélation Scott Summers et
Emma Frost des X-Men sont mariés Peter
Parker est en couple avec Gwen Stacy et
ont tous les deux un enfant mais encore
plus troublant hawkaï et de nouveau en
vie c'est alors que nous passons dans le
point de vue de Wolverine présent durant
le meeting pour savoir quoi faire de
Wanda le héros un la star de tous va
comprendre pas dans le bon monde était
moins que personne ne se souvient de ce
qu'il s'est passé tentera de trouver des
réponses nous sommes en fait dans un
monde où Magnéto et devenu le leader et
où les mutants ont pris le dessus sur
les humains nous apprenons d'ailleurs
que mcdoos règne sur la ville accompagné
de sa famille et ses petits-enfants
suspectant qu'héritent alias Magnéto et
la cause de tout ça Wolverine va essayer
de raviver la mémoire de ses congénères
grâce à Emma Frost qui est normalement
la chef des X-Men et doté de pouvoir
télékinétiques nos héros vont pouvoir se
rendre compte qu'ils ont été dupés et
que leur vie actuelle n'est qu'un
mensonge une fois regroupé tout le monde
partira pour le château de Magnéto afin
de le confronter durant la bataille
Docteur Strange en projection astrale
détectera une source de lumière depuis
l'une des chambres du Château et là-bas
il fera la rencontre d'une Honda
complètement isolée en train de jouer
avec ses enfants Steven tentera avec
douceur de lui demander ce qu'il s'est
passé et la Scarlet twitch va dévoiler à
Dr Strange comment ce nouveau monde est
né nous sommes témoins d'une scène très
poignante entre Pietro et Wanda quand
Quicksilver effondré avec Manito Wanda
était en fait réveiller et à tout
entendu Pietro est alors allé à son
chevet pour la prendre dans ses bras et
Wanda en pleurs nous affirme qu'elle ne
cherchera pas à fuir il n'y a pas
d'issue à ses yeux les Avengers auraient
même dû la tuer pour elle après ce
qu'elle a fait à ses coéquipiers elle se
sent même lâche de ne pas réussir à
mettre fin à sa propre vie Pietro
dégoûtée rassurera sa sœur en lui
affirmant que ce n'est pas de sa faute
la vie n'a jamais été tendre avec eux
ils n'ont jamais eu le choix magnéto a
préféré sa fameuse race des mutants
plutôt que ses enfants ils auraient dû
être une famille c'est ce dont Pietro et
Wanda ont toujours rêvé eux qui ont été
abandonnés et ont survie depuis leur le
seul moment de bonheur qu'ils ont eu au
final c'est quand ils étaient des
Avengers et ils regrette cette époque
c'est alors qu'une idée va émerger dans
la tête de Pietro Wanda allait capacités
grâce à son pouvoir de changer le monde
et de rendre chacun heureux que ce soit
les Avengers les X-Men ou encore magnéto
ils ont toujours choisi et orientés le
destin du frère et de la sœur et au
final d'après eux Wanda devrait mourir
et bien c'est hors de question grâce à
la condition de Wanda ils ont les moyens
de changer tout ça et prendre le
contrôle de leur avenir Docteur Strange
sera surpris de voir qu'au final magnéto
niait absolument pour rien ses pieds
trop qui a finalement causé tout ça
magneus réveillé par herma Frost entrera
directement dans une colère noire et
partira instantanément confronté son
fils qui s'est servi de son nom pour
bâtir ce nouveau monde Pietro enragé
affirmera qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
solutions Magnéto et les autres héros à
les tuer sa sœur du coup ils ont préféré
bâtir un monde où tout le monde serait
heureux ou tout le monde aurait ce
qu'ils ont toujours souhaité c'est
pourquoi makhnous et le dirigeant et que
les mutants sont majoritaires au terme
du combat dans sa rage magnéto va tuer
son propre fils et horrifié Wanda la
Scarlett witch incontrôlable va
intervenir cette dernière va raviver son
frère et dans son monologue va défendre
le désir pur de son frère de rendre tout
le monde heureux y compris son père
Wanda accuse magnéto tout ceci c'est à
cause de lui il a préféré son désir
égoïste de supériorité plutôt que ses
enfants il a choisi de faire des
conquêtes contre l'humanité au nom des
mutants au lieu de s'occuper de sa
famille et alors que Wanda et Pietro
dans leur souffrance ont tenté en vain
de rendre heureux leur père en lui
donnant ce qu'il a toujours voulu mcnus
a finalement son propre fils de colère
c'est inacceptable les mutants ne sont
pas l'étape suivante de l'humanité ce
sont juste des monstres des monstres
comme Wanda et Pietro qui ont été
façonnés notamment par les désirs
tyranniques de personnes comme magnéto
dans un silence assourdissant suivant le
discours de détresse de Wanda la
scarletwitch les larmes aux yeux
prononcera trois mots trois petits mots
qui changeront à jamais le cours de
l'Histoire
nos morts Newtons le monde va retrouver
son état normal tout sera comme avant
mais pas exactement et ma Frost qui se
souvient des événements effrayés et
partira à toute vitesse utilisez le
Cérébro pour détecter les mutants
présents sur la planète et à la surprise
générale alors qu'ils étaient plus d'un
million on en compte désormais que
quelques dizaines de milliers ce jour
restera marqué au fer rouge dans
l'histoire des mutants comme le MDA tout
le monde partira à la recherche de Wanda
mais malheureusement ces dernières
restera introuvable
est-ce que Wanda est véritablement à
blâmer dans cette célèbre histoire qui
est House of M la question est
intéressante car en soi oui dans la
forme c'est Wanda qui a agi mais dans le
fond c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
House of M additionné à Avengers disas
sombeld c'est le résultat et je dirais
même la récolte de ce que les héros ont
semé Wanda depuis son premier comics n'a
jamais véritablement brillé ou était mis
en lumière bien au contraire elle a
toujours été plus ou moins
instrumentalisée par ses ennemis bien
sûr comme dans le cas d'octone qui se
sert de Wanda comme réceptacle ou encore
Immortus qui a tenté de tracer la vidéo
Wanda mais aussi par les Avengers qui
ont toujours mis de côté la souffrance
de Wanda pour le pseudo bien de l'équipe
sans oublier également les X-Men qui
dans leur éternel conflit entre mutants
ne voyait qu'en Wanda un simple pion
pour grossir les rangs et magnéto on en
parle même pas ce n'est pas un hasard si
Wanda le désigne comme la cause de tout
ce qui est arrivé le désigné à cause de
son égoïsme à gâché la vie de ses
enfants et ses services d'eux pour sa
vieille cause et malheureusement avec
l'éveil de la magie du chaos et bien nos
héros craignent même désormais leur
allier au point de la traille et de lui
faire des secrets comme pour le cas de
ses enfants nous sommes clairement face
à une instrumentalisation de Wanda et de
toute sa vie la jeune femme n'a pas de
libre arbitre elle ne peut jamais faire
ce qu'elle a envie même Docteur Strange
qui ose blâmer les Avengers n’est pas
tout rose dans cette histoire car quand
on y réfléchit un peu bien que
l'initiative de Steven soit quand même
juste de vouloir faire de Wanda une
disciple pour qu'elle apprenne à mieux
maîtriser ses pouvoirs l'intention est
bonne et bien derrière c'est quand même
pour éviter que Wanda ne fasse trop d'un
gris et influence l'univers il y a un
but en gros derrière la bonne action et
c'est tout le temps comme ça avec Wonda
la malheureuse sorcière s'est vu
octroyer un pouvoir beaucoup trop
immense et cela l'oriente vers toujours
plus de de France House of M symbolise
le craquage personne ne s'est intéressé
à comment Wanda vivaient les choses ou
si au moins elle avait son mot à dire
non que ce soit les Avengers ou les
X-Men ils se sont contentés de faire des
meetings pour juger l'une de leurs plus
fidèles alliés et quand ils se sont
enfin dit que peut-être ce serait
intéressant d'avoir l'avis de Wanda
là-dedans et bien c'est trop tard en
fait bref tout ceci est passionnant mais
il est temps de passer au dernier arc de
la vidéo décidément l'année 2005 sera
une année riche pour l'histoire des
comics et plus particulièrement celle de
Wanda car en réalité à peu près au même
moment de la sortie de House of M va
émerger une nouvelle série de comics
mettant en vedette une petite équipe de
super-héros désigné comme les Young
Avengers et si je vous en parle ce n'est
pas pour rien puisque dans l'équipe nous
retrouvons un certain William Caplan et
Thomas Shepherd deux enfants dont et
diminutifs sont Billy et Tommy vous
l'aurez compris ces deux adolescents ne
sont pas n'importe qui cependant ils
n'ont désormais rien à voir avec ce
qu'ils étaient à l'époque ils sont
aujourd'hui
issus de deux familles différentes et
complètement lambda alors que s'est-il
passé et bien notre histoire commence
dès le comics 11 des Young Avengers
sorti le 5 avril 2006 alors qu'un
nouveau conflit crie et scroll commence
à se profiler dû à la récente révélation
que Teddy Altman alias hulking le petit
ami de Billy et le fils de Captain
Marvel et d'une princesse Kroll nos deux
jeunes gens durant la bataille vont
finalement sauver le super scroll qui a
été désigné pour veiller sur Teddy face
à l'ironie de la situation le super
scroll ne pourra pas s'empêcher de
rétorquer que lors de la toute première
guerre entre les cris et les Scrolls sur
terre Marvel et lascaret twitch était
ses prisonniers et aujourd'hui ce sont
finalement leur fils qui viennent de le
sauver Billy sera interloquée car il
n'est pas du tout le fils de Wanda
Maximov pourtant le super scroll affirme
le contraire d'après le savoir scroll la
scarletwitch à bel et bien eu deux
enfants deux jumeaux du nom de Thomas et
William chamboulé Billy ira retrouver
son coéquipier speed et tous les deux se
serviront de la base de données de
vision pour trouver des réponses il nous
sera révélé l'histoire que nous
connaissons Wanda était si désespéré de
ne pas avoir d'enfant qu'elle a conçu
ses jumeaux à partir de la magie du
chaos et les âmes des progénitures ont
finalement été réclamés par Mephisto
ensuite après la bataille contre le
démon les âmes des enfants ont
finalement été libérés et on cessait
d'exister jusqu'à récemment où la
Scarlet twitch a pété les plombs et tuer
ces trois coéquipiers Avengers pour
Tommy c'est n'importe quoi mais pour
Billy cela fait complètement sens il a
les pouvoirs de Wanda et Tommy à les
pouvoirs de Quicksilver les âmes des
enfants après avoir été libérés par
Méphisto ont fini par revenir sur Terre
dans d'autres familles qui n'ont rien à
voir cela peut sembler fou quand on y
pense mais tous les petits détails mis
bout à bout confirme cette théorie les
deux enfants veulent désormais en savoir
plus ils veulent à partir de maintenant
découvrir la vérité l'histoire va
finalement reprendre son cours les Young
Avengers vivront de nombreux aventures
et accompagneront même les véritables
Avengers à certains moments jusqu'à ce
que quelque chose d'inattendu fasse son
apparition et chamboule nos super-héros
si oui Cannes et bel et bien le fils de
la Scarlet twitch et a donc
hérité de ses pouvoirs cela signifie
qu'il est en possession de la magie du
chaos une magie dite incontrôlable et
capable d'altérer la réalité pendant un
affrontement Teddy le petit ami de
William sera menacé et sous le coup de
la colère et de la peur billy va
provoquer inconsciemment une gigantesque
explosion de magie qui va décimer ses
ennemis inquiets de ce qui vient de se
produire les Avengers interrogerons sur
le cas du jeune super héros est-ce que
ce ne serait pas l'arrivée d'une
scarlate witch 2.0 week-end en
s'entretenant avec ses mentors se rendra
finalement compte que Wanda est un
véritable sujet tabou elle est
considérée comme responsable des
événements de House of M elle est
désignée comme une assassin après ce
qu'elle a fait à ses coéquipiers du coup
en réalité la perte de contrôle des
pouvoirs de Billy tant l'équipe des
Avengers plus qu'autre chose ils n'ont
pas envie de revivre les sombres
événements reliés à la sorcière notre
jeune super-héros va alors tenter une
fugue sauf que magnéto lui-même va
apparaître pour rencontrer ces deux
petits-fils le vieux mutant nous informe
qu'il est lui aussi en quête de
retrouver Wanda sa fille il a laissé
derrière lui toutes ses conquêtes et
semble avoir appris de ses erreurs
depuis les événements de House of M bien
évidemment c'est dur de faire confiance
à Magnéto et nos Young Avengers vont
douter de la véracité ses attentions
mais comprenant qu'il n'est désormais
plus possible de faire confiance aux
Avengers qui ont été trop meurtris à
cause des actions de sa supposée mère
les Young Avengers iront avec magnéto à
transia au pied du mont Wonder la ville
d'origine de la scarletwitch là-bas
magnos révèlera qu'il recherche sa fille
depuis un long moment étant sur la terre
qui a écrit l'histoire de sa famille il
en profitera pour dévoiler le récit de
sa vie à sceptifice une piste va
finalement apparaître sauf que surprise
cela ne va pas conduire notre groupe
vers Wanda mais vers son frère Pietro
Quiksilver de par les infos connaît déjà
ses neveux néanmoins il est très en
colère car toute cette histoire vient de
conduire son détesté père magnéto face à
lui et cela veut dire que ses neveux
sont déjà sous l'emprise de leur
grand-père week-end tentera alors de
rassurer son oncle lui affirmant que lui
et son frère sont venus de leur plein
gré et magnéto rétorquera qu'il souhaite
réparer son passé sauf que Pietro n'est
pas dupe la dernière fois qu'il a voulu
faire confiance à son père ce dernier a
tenté de le tuer Pietro va alors engager
le combat et s'armer de plusieurs pieux
ou autre bout de bois qui lancera en
direction de son père mais à la surprise
générale une jeune femme au physique
familier passée par là et la malheureuse
finira empaler avant de tomber au sol
nos personnages arrêteront
instantanément le combat croyant que la
jeune protagoniste est Wanda mais ce
n'est pas le cas le physique est le même
mais la fausse Rwanda est en réalité un
robot et vu la précision et le réalisme
de la machine seul une personne est
capable de faire ça seul leur n'est pas
n'importe quelle botte c'est un doombot
Wanda Maximov et retenu prisonnière du
docteur Doom le célèbre antagoniste
alliant la magie et la technologie
autoproclamé souverain du royaume de la
laverie on ne parle pas ici de n'importe
qui même magnéto est inquiet le château
de doume est une véritable forteresse et
politiquement parlant envahir ce dernier
c'est lui déclarait la guerre donc il
faut bien réfléchir à comment agir pour
sauver Wanda cependant la nuit tombée ne
trouvant pas le sommeil et ne voulant
pas risquer la vie de ses alliés dans
une quête qu'il considère comme
personnel week-end va se téléporter seul
à l'insu de tous dans ce royaume là-bas
William fera face à la véritable Wanda
maximum sauf que quelque chose cloche
cette dernière ne se souvient de rien
son père magnéto jamais entendu parler
son véritable père est mort Quicksilver
son frère il doit y avoir une erreur et
en plus de cela week-end affirme qu'il
est venu pour la sauver des griffes du
docteur Doom mais cela n'a pas de sens
puisque ouanda est en sécurité et mieux
que ça elle va se marier au docteur
lui-même demain doum s'entend que
quelque chose se trame son château
interviendra de lui-même un affrontement
va alors s'enclencher entre lui et le
jeune mage week-end tentera par tous les
moyens avant de se faire battre
d'éveiller les souvenirs de Rwanda en
vain et à son réveil Billy sera
finalement soigné par le docteur doum
qui souhaite entretenir avec lui il
comprend ce que c'est de faire le jeune
garçon il sait qu'il veut le bien de
Wanda mais la Scarlet twitch ne doit en
aucun cas renouer avec son passé qu'elle
réprime inconsciemment week-end
évidemment c'est à qui il a affaire il
suspecte que le docteur hakidnappé Wanda
pour ses pouvoirs et la détient
prisonnière mais ce dernier nous affirme
le contraire Wanda seul et abandonné est
venu de son plein gré pour demander de
l'aide et le destin étant bien fait les
deux protagonistes sont finalement
tombés amoureux weekend a donc le choix
soit il peut venir en tant qu'inviter au
mariage ou bien il rester enfermés dans
une chambre en tant que prisonnier c'est
alors que quelques temps plus tard Wanda
en robe de mariée fera irruption pour
s'entretenir avec le jeune garçon car sa
vie en Lasy était sublime jusqu'à ce que
ce dernier apparaisse Victor n'est
désormais plus le même homme Rwanda est
intrigué elle veut tout savoir
concernant cette fameuse Scarlet twitch
William lui comptera alors toute son
histoire notamment cette tragique épopée
où elle a eu deux enfants qu'elle a
perdu mais une fois arrivé dehors nos
deux personnages découvriront que leur
royaume du docteur Doom est à feu et à
100 les Young Avengers se magnéto Pietro
et même la véritable équipe des Avengers
est présente pour déclarer la guerre à
Victor van Doom pour retrouver Wanda
Victor enragé par ce que week-end a fait
car pour lui c'est de sa faute s'il a
Lady est devenu un champ de bataille
tentera de tuer le jeune garçon et Wanda
choqué par les actions de son bien-aimé
lui demandera d'arrêter Doom posera
alors la question à Wanda de si elle
croit l'histoire que lui a compté Billy
mais bien sûr que non elle n'y croit pas
en revanche ce qui la tracasse c'est
pourquoi Doom et si inquiet que ces
dernières est prête à croire à tout ça
la jeune femme va alors fuguer avec
William et ces derniers vont retrouver
l'équipe des junghe Avengers grâce à
Iron lad qui est un kangle conquérant
adolescent et fondateur de l'équipe des
Jung Avengers nos héros vont pouvoir
s'échapper dans le flux temporel et
voyageront dans le passé pour raviver
les souvenirs de la Scarlet twitch
cassylang la fille d'antan très
désireuse de retrouver son père initiera
le groupe à retourner au moment où
Scotland et décédé là-bas nous
retrouverons le fameux Jack le Valet de
Coeur ramené depuis les morts destinés à
causer l'explosion qui va tuer Ant-Man
sachant le tragique évènement destiné à
se produire nos héros fuiront mais Wanda
contre toute attente ira faire face à
son défunt allié qui a ramener à cause
d'elle après l'explosion tout le monde
sera ramené dans le présent sauf Kyron
lad qui est normalement l'expert du
voyage dans le temps n'y est pour rien
alors comment c'est possible et bien
Wanda grâce à ce voyage à retrouver ses
plaines capacités et sa mémoire c'est
elle qui vient de ramener tout le monde
dans le présent elle nous explique
finalement les raisons qui l'ont poussé
à causer tant d'atrocité dans son passé
elle voulait que les Avengers
expérimentent le sentiment de perte que
ces derniers soient face à leur propre
péché et leurs erreurs mais aujourd'hui
c'est l'heure des réparations Wanda va
arranger les événements néanmoins elle
ressent toujours autant de culpabilité
par rapport à ce qu'elle a fait c'est
alors que ouikan inquiet pour sa mère
interviendra pour lui dire qu'après
toutes ces péripéties ses amis sont
finalement toujours en vie et il
trouvera même enfin le courage de lui
affirmer qu'il est son fils Wanda ému ne
pourra pas péché de le prendre dans ses
bras et comprendra directement que Billy
dit vrai au final c'est la révélation
que malgré tous les malheurs qui se sont
produits wanda est capable de réparer
tout ça elle peut inverser le cours des
choses et le fauve des X-Men désormais
conscient de ça incitera la scarletwitch
à inverser le MDA nos héros iront à la
rencontre du groupe X Factor et Wanda
grâce à ses pouvoirs redonnera à rector
l'un des mutants victimes du MDA ces
aptitudes cependant les nouvelles à
l'envite les Avengers et le groupe de
X-Men interviendront par la suite pour
juger Wanda la totalité des personnages
rentreront dans un conflit pour savoir
quoi faire de la scarletwitch car
personne n'est d'accord certains veulent
la protéger d'autres veulent la justice
certains ont soif de vengeance bref
c'est un véritable bazar agacé par les
autres personnages qui veulent décider
son destin comme toujours la Scarlet
twitch va plonger tout le monde dans le
sommeil et ira retrouver dôme la seule
personne en qui elle a désormais
confiance dans le but de redonner leur
pouvoir aux mutants après quelques
dialogues Doom va nous révéler qu'à
l'époque si Wanda était allé à la
rencontre du souverain c'est parce
qu'elle était désespérée par rapport à
la nouvelle de la perte de ses enfants
et souhaitez éperdument les ramener pour
ce faire grâce à sa condition d'être
Nexus alliés à la magie du chaos Doom et
Wanda ont travaillé pour imprégner la
jeune femme de la magie capable
d'influencer la vie elle-même sauf que
malheureusement c'était trop de pouvoir
pour la jeune femme et cela lui a fait
perdre la raison au point de tuer ses
coéquipiers et causer les événements de
House of M désireuse désormais
d'inverser le cours des choses Wanda va
demander à Victor de la libérer du
pouvoir de la vie et que le monarque une
fois en sa possession redonne au mutants
leur capacités Wanda William et le
docteur Doom alors entamer un rituel
pour octroyer la magie incontrôlable à
Victor c'est le retour du gode Emperor
Doom un être
omnipotent capable de tout et
malheureusement vous vous en doutez mais
Doom reste Doom il n'a en aucun cas
prévu de redonner leur pouvoir au
mutants une fois tout-puissant il va
renvoyer Wanda et les Young Avengers à
New York où cette dernière devra
confronter la colère des autres héros
sauf que cette fois-ci il y en a marre
et Billy va bien nous le faire savoir
oui Wanda a causé beaucoup de mal mais
elle a été victime des autres la plupart
du temps alors pourquoi un tel
acharnement sur elle après tout la
majorité des super héros sont des êtres
douteux magnéto est l'un des plus
grandes vilains de la firme pourtant les
X-Men l'ont désormais accepté dans leur
équipe et soit dit en passant l'équipe
des X-Men actuelle est quand même
composée d'ex assassin ou or la loi et
c'est pareil pour les Aven donc qui
sont-ils pour juger le cas de Wanda
personne et cette prise de conscience va
permettre à tout le monde de pouvoir
s'unir face aux désormais omnipotent
docteur Doom le combat sera extrêmement
rude mais à terme la solution sera
trouvée par la Scarlett witch accompagné
de son fils Billy les deux protagonistes
sachant le pouvoir de la vie
incontrôlable vont provoquer un rituel
permettant à Doom d'obtenir encore plus
de pouvoir et c'est quelque chose qui va
le déséquilibrer et le faire tomber
Wanda toujours inquiète pour son
bien-aimé voudra aller à sa rescousse
mais docteur Doom enragé par sa défaite
et le retour de ses imperfections
insultera la sorcière pour lui Wanda
n'est qu'une créature qui lui a servi de
conduit pour atteindre le pouvoir cette
dernière s'est cru capable de détruire
les Avengers c'est le monde des mutants
elle est mentalement beaucoup trop
faible pour ça c'est Doom qui s'est
servi d'elle pour générer ses événements
après le combat Doom s'en ira et Wanda
désormais in présenter après ses
révélations sera enfin libérée des
autres héros Magnéto et Pietro lui
proposeront alors de partir avec elle
pour se retrouver en famille mais la
jeune femme déclinera l'offre toute sa
vie elle était considérée comme la sœur
de Pietro la fille de Manito l'épouse de
vision il est désormais temps pour
Rwanda de se concentrer sur elle et
prendre ses responsabilités elle est la
scarletwitch elle a retrouvé ses enfants
la seule chose qu'elle a véritablement
toujours désiré et elle nous a prouvé
qu'elle était capable d'inverser ce
qu'elle a causé c'est à présent vers
tout ça qu'elle souhaite se diriger
[Musique]
sincèrement l'épopée children's Creed
des Avengers est une saga que je vous
conseille vraiment de lire il y a tout
dans cette histoire c'est une véritable
apogée pour Wanda l'instrumentalisation
du personnage par docteur Doom qui s'est
servi d'elle comme c'est la toujours été
dans son histoire dans les comics
l'hypocrisie des autres héros qui comme
toujours souhaitent décider du destin de
leur ami qui n'a pas son mot à dire et
qu'il craigne d'ailleurs dont ils ont
peur mais au final nous finirons quand
même face à une véritable happy hand
pour Rwanda et je dirais même une
rédemption déjà Wanda a retrouvé ses
enfants ce qui était son plus profond
désir et elle a enfin eu mais surtout le
plus important la saga va nous prouver
que si les autres personnages avaient
été plus attentifs envers Wanda et lui
avait fait confiance et que cette
dernière avait véritablement son libre
arbitre et bien rien de tout ça ne se
serait passé puisque Wanda de son plein
gré quand elle est libre et bah au final
c'est elle qui va ramener ses
coéquipiers à la vie c'est elle qui va
solutionner les événements d'Avengers
disasumbled et d'elle-même elle va
redonner ses pouvoirs à un mutant mais
quand elle n'avait plus son libre
arbitre et qu'elle était sous l'emprise
encore une fois d'un antagoniste qui
cette fois-ci est docteur Doom et bien
c'est là où elle a causé d'innombrables
problèmes mais tout ça du coup c'est
indépendamment de sa volonté par le
biais de cette histoire Wanda malgré la
souffrance nous approuvé qu'elle n'a
jamais été une ennemi mais bien au
contraire quelle est l'une des plus
grandes héroïnes de l'univers Marvel et
l'épopée est encore plus poignante quand
on se rend compte que le seul personnage
qui a réussi à lui donner raison est un
simple enfant rempli d'espoir qui
souhaite simplement retrouver sa mère la
conclusion de l'épopée est d'ailleurs je
trouve parfaite car elle résume
véritablement les 50 années de comics
que symbolise l'histoire de Rwanda elle
a toujours été guidée malgré elle elle a
toujours été
secondaire la sœur de Pietro la fille de
Magnéto la femme de vision la
coéquipière des Avengers tout ça c'est
désormais terminé Wanda a enfin trouvé
la liberté et il est temps pour elle de
prendre ses responsabilités et son envol
et tout ce que je vous raconte depuis le
début de la vidéo et bien c'est tout ça
qui rend Wanda maximum la Scarlet witch
si unique
J'espère de tout cœur que la vidéo vous
aura plu car c'était un sacré morceau je
suis trop heureux de vous avoir compté
l'histoire de Wanda car personnellement
je la trouve passionnante c'est l'une de
mes héroïnes préférées et comparée à
d'autres personnages je trouve qu'elle a
quand même pas mal de thématiques assez
particulière bien évidemment nous
n'aurons pas pu parler de tout mais bon
vu la durée de la vidéo j'estime quand
même vous avoir démontré l'unicité du
personnage si la vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez surtout pas à me le faire
savoir via un commentaire ou avec un
beau pouce bleu ou les deux et n'oubliez
pas non plus de vous abonner pour ne pas
louper les prochaines vidéos sur ce les
amis merci à tous d'avoir regardé cet
état rock que le lion Hart soit avec
vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]